his name is I believe Adam look I
actually empathize with the people of
Gaza you know they have a term called
Jihad which is a holy war it's a
two-part War uh one is the spiritual
struggle internally and one is the
external struggle which literally means
killing people on behalf of your uh your
belief but people think there's some
something that Muslims inherently they
hate Jews or when the prophet Muhammad
went to Medina he uplifted Jews and
women how did he do that let me quote
you Paul a Jewish scholar by the name of
Dr David Warstein he wrote Islam saved
the jewy means Islam saved the Jewish
people so the number one reason that he
gave is that uh the Jewish people they
were at the brink of Extinction who told
you that the Arabs were going to kill us
we had great relations with the Muslims
and the Arabs back in the day you know
his family lived in Hebron and his half
family lived in Jerusalem that always
had you know Jewish minorities he said
we had great relations we share the same
values we Shar the similar culture you
know we all treat each other with
respect it was only only when the
believe me I always had um hopes in
Jordan Peterson but H that he failed
when Palestine is free people like him
are going to be ashamed that they did
this now I really have hopes in uh
Patrick uh uh Patrick on the contrary
the Muslims and the Arab people were for
us our friends and our patrons the ones
who protect us and provide a safe haven
this guy right here this guy's trying to
build a DA Center in our country I'm not
talking to you right now you're a solo
you're trying to build a daah center
here Islam is violent by Nature asalam
brothers and sisters this is exactly why
we need the dean Center because we have
over 300 million Americans who know
nothing about Islam like this guy hey
you want to have a talk yeah this guy's
trying to build a DA Center in our
country Surah 9 is the most violent
chapter of the Quran the dean Center
will will be a source of light a mega
daa Center an educational center helping
our brothers and sisters in humanity
truly understand Islam and Muslims and
brothers and sisters remember the great
rewards of just guiding one person in
humanity to the truth is better than
everything in this duny so get in on all
the rewards and blessings click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of
[Music]
you assalam alaikum greetings of peace
welcome to the D show May your host go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
notification Bell so you can get up to
date with all of the current shows that
come out my next guest she fidil sulan
is the Masters in Islamic Studies is an
international speaker orator filmmaker
and presenter of Islam he started the
bridges foundation in
2005 with the aim of Connecting People
of different backgrounds to help them
understand Islam and Muslims he has made
three films about Islam the series are
called the fog is lifting Islam in brief
and Jihad get this Jihad on
terrorism and which has been translated
into 31 languages now something that's
very interesting that we're going to be
talking about he's actually been
implementing because recently there's
been a lot of talk about the discussion
the debate of the year and the pbd
podcast with Patrick been David so he's
been actually implementing Patrick's
vision of Muslims and Christians and
others working together against what
Patrick calls the greater enemy what he
has to share is very interesting to say
the least but first first we're going to
have him react to something else that
was just I think yesterday or day before
yesterday what was broadcast on the pdb
pbd podcast regarding Islam Muslims and
Jad so so let's get into this clip and
we'll get right into bringing our next
guest out when I was ready to talk about
I would I was explaining how much
respect I have for the faith of
Islam expert but I've been there a bunch
and I know people and I have friends and
this is this is you know Israel is the
only democracy in the Middle East even
close and uh so you ask like who are
your allies pbd is coming out with a
book called choose your enemies wisely
look I actually empathize with the
people of Gaza you know they have a term
called Jihad which is a holy war it's a
two-part War uh one is the spiritual
struggle internally and one is the
external struggle which literally means
killing people on behalf of your uh your
belief butum we start with the greeting
of peace peace be unto you how are you
doing
long time no see yes yes good to have
you on the program again yeah so you got
to see this clip now oh yeah before
before we get into Patrick's Vision you
got to see the discussion debate of the
year and we were going to do some
commentary on that and give some
practical actually you going deeper into
this uh with the whole alphabet movement
and everything else this came up this is
your specialty this is what your
documentary revolves around this term
Jihad yeah how would you react to this
this is I believe Sam when I was down
there I actually got to meet Patrick
really nice guy and we had a good time
together and then actually I met Vinnie
Vinnie is also someone who is part of
the podcast met him real nice guy he
actually has he showed me his tattoo he
has uh an Arabic he has a I think it was
if I'm not mistaken alhamdulillah tattoo
oh oh praise to God yeah last week alone
200 Palestinians were killed guide them
Allah guide them both a mean a mean and
uh this one I believe I didn't meet him
his name is I believe Adam and we're
going to assume Adam like most people
they just hear what they've been kind of
programmed through through the media and
and much of the uh hate industry the
islamophobic industry so they catch
these things these talking points how do
you address this how would you react to
Adam and others who got to hear this
misinformation they have a term called
Jihad which is a holy war it's a
two-part War uh one is the spiritual
struggle internally and one is the
external struggle which literally means
killing people on behalf of your
uh your belief but funny thing is that
he he said that Jihad means holy war
actually holy war is a Christian term
first heard in the Crusades Pope Urban
II who launched the Crusades by calling
all Christians in Europe to war against
Muslims in order to reclaim the holy
land and he cried out do Vault God wills
it so the word holy war by the way in
Islam war is not holy
God acknowledges in the Quran that
Muslims hate war God said inah Al Bak uh
which is chapter number two sign number
216 combat has been prescribed upon you
even though you dislike it so God
actually acknowledges that Muslims
dislike war and then he says but it may
be that you dislike something while it
is good for you and maybe that you like
something that is bad for you for Allah
knows and you know not so God prescribed
not holy world combat on Muslims but
there is actually um a combat code which
is a long it's a long talk about that
but war in Islam is Haram forbidden
except if it is in the form of
jihad what is Jihad to cut it short
Jihad is war on
terrorism and that's why we need to know
what is Terrorism you know that in 2005
Eddie 150 monarchs and presidents met in
a summit in the United Nations to Define
terrorism and after three days the
summit ended without a definition you
know why because had they accept the
definition of political scientists at
least 50% of them have to go to jail
immediately
wow yes of course according to political
scientists uh terrorism is targeting
non- combatants to support a political
or an economic agenda targeting not
killing because you may Target people
and you don't kill them maybe you just
injure them just targeting them makes it
terrorism and it's non combatants not
civilians because some civilians are
combatants and they are called militia
those are actually legal targets but
targeting non-combatants to support a
political or an economic agenda and and
this means that most of the terrorism
that is carried out is carried out by
States state terrorism not actually
individuals or groups Alone look at
chapter number fourah Ana uh sign number
75 it
says
it means god is blaming Muslims if they
don't go to combat in this case and what
is the matter with you that you do not
combat in the way of Allah and for the
once deemed weak and oppressed among men
women and children those who are
non-combatants suffering from oppression
those are what they are suffering from
terrorism so Jihad means war on
terrorism God is telling Muslims how
come you don't fight terrorism Jihad
equals war and terrorism but the real
one not war for oil and then call it war
on terrorism so I wish that this uh
person this uh man who appeared saying
so would educate himself better about
Jihad he has to understand how come the
word Jihad scares people in the west but
people use it to name their children
even girls you can find a a three old
girl with rosy cheeks and and her name
is Jihad she dos you my name is Jihad
why would Arab people or Muslim people
call their children girls Jihad it's
definitely something beautiful something
nice he has to understand what it means
because this Gap in understanding it is
really um dangerous that's
it what's your comments on this uh this
is the statement of the last and final
message sent to mankind Prophet Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him uh you
seeing this up on the was this this is
way before the Geneva conventions huh
yes exactly and these are actually the
uh Commandments of prophet Muhammad to
the uh actually of Abu Bakr sik to the
army of Usama Usama was a
16-year-old uh uh Chief uh uh of of an
army whom Prophet Muhammad wasallam
wanted to uh uh mobilize him and with
Army and then the prophet died so they
were mobilized by Abu Bakr sik the first
khif and he told them exactly these
instructions which are on a poster in
the uh United Nations actually it is I
think the um the Red Cross uh in in
Geneva you see uh Adam here on the pbd
podcast he starts off with he
sympathizes with the Palestinian people
but they have this term that you just
defined Jihad so what we got here the
facts Jihad does not mean holy war yeah
you number two you you mentioned uh the
the pope this actually was coined during
the Christian Crusades people can go
look this up correct yeah yeah exactly
what was the pope's name what was the PO
name urban thei Urban II yes and then
okay so we got this out of the way now
if somebody it's just like you know you
you come to someone and you think that
um you think is Christmas and then
someone say no they celebrate this H
it's Christmas no it's not Christmas
it's totally something different right
so you so now you've defined it clearly
CLE clearly what it is uh the term is
translated what is it linguistically
Translate g uh to struggle and strive
jih had linguist has three main meanings
a linguistic meaning which is to do an
extra effort any extra effort is Jihad
and there is also a spiritual meaning
which which is to strive against oneself
against your ego against your so he
metion he me he me he he mentioned that
part yeah so go ahead yeah he mentioned
that one yeah so there is also a
spiritual meaning and there is something
called uh um the biggest Jihad which is
to to say a word of Truth in the
presence of a tyrant the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him said the
biggest form of jihad is a word of Truth
in the presence of a tyrant what do
tyrants do tyrants k H Prophet Muhammad
is encouraging people to stand against
tence and say the truth even if this can
lead to their own demise because we all
are gonna die one day but if people are
silent when they see uh a corruption
this will lead to more corruption so a
community or a society of Silent People
is a community or a society of devils
they we have to speak and the the last
tar type of jihad is combative Jihad and
there's a code for combative for combat
it's called the code of
combat gotcha okay so then uh so this
this whole idea it seemed like what he
was saying he misinformed there is that
like Muslims have this Jad this one
spiritual part fighting off you know the
devil and fighting off the nefs you know
the inner self the ego and all that
stuff it's good but then they got this
thing there it's you know it's this holy
war and and that's what you got to kind
of like
contradicts in itself what he just said
that holy war which is to go and kill
people everywhere no I'm sorry how can
you be a good person and you struggle
against your NFS against your ego
against your evil inclinations and you
go go kill people everywhere it's
exactly what Robert Spencer said you
have kill them whatever you find them
whatever you find them where in
supermarkets if he just continues to say
the whole uh uh sign the whole sign says
that until the war is over so this is in
war and wherever you find them it's
about people whom their country was
occupied God is telling people and is
encouraging Muslims not to accept
occupation this is the problem of
Muslims what people don't understand the
our problem is that we do not believe
that God promised anybody the Holy Land
our land so are we supposed to just
accept when we find people coming from
Europe 70 80 years ago fleeing the
persecution and we welcome them actually
the the Jews were welcomed by the
Palestinians we're giving them shelter
we're giving them places to live and
they had no problems until they found
that oh there's an agenda here here
started the problem are we supposed to
accept what other scriptures say no I'm
sorry I don't believe in that I don't
believe in that don't tell me that God
promised you 3,000 years ago that my
land will be your land and then you kick
me out in the sea this is completely
this is insane
uh one more thing before we get into the
alphabet movement and your experiences
now working together actually going to
Christian conferences and yeah you know
giving giving uh your feedback your
advice and listening how we can work
together I I want you to get your
comments on this this is from um
actually a good friend of mine Dr seil
because uh this is the current situation
that's going on and people think there's
some something that Muslims inherently
they hate Jews or whatnot uh I want to
get your reaction to this we don't hate
Jews actually when the prophet Muhammad
went to Medina he uplifted Jews and
women how did he do that let me quote
you Paul a Jewish scholar by the name of
Dr David Warstein he wrote Islam saved
the jewy means Islam saved the Jewish
people so the number one reason that he
gave is that uh the Jewish people they
were at the brink of
Extinction around the birth of Muhammad
peace be upon him the Persians the
Egyptians the Romans and others they
were all praying on the Jewish people
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him he
gave the Jewish uh groups in Medina
autonomy the second reason that he gave
is the Spanish Inquisition so when the
Jewish people when they KCK when they
were kicked out they went to the Muslim
land the Ottoman Empire and yes
Palestine so again Muslims and Islam
they gave them the freedom and the
protection in the land to the Jewish
people a forgot in history by the way
you don't hear much about this in the
schools nowadays do you in the
universities what are your comments on
that is there is this um something that
just made up by Muslims no no no no this
is history this is history well Jews
have always found a safe haven with
Muslims in the Muslim World by the way
the closest to to the Muslims in AA in
beliefs are the Jews actually not the
Christians the Christian theology is
completely different from us but the
Jewish theology is very close to us when
it comes toed and stuff like that a lot
but so we didn't have a problem even
what we eat you know I eat freely when I
eat in a Jewish restaurant I don't care
I don't even ask if it's Halal or not I
don't care if it's if it's kosher then
that's fine so we don't have a big
problem with each other we have a
problem with occupiers we have a problem
with with oppressors whether the
oppressors are Muslims or Jews or
Christians so is the difference here the
the when you um differentiate Jewish
because there's a lot of I've
interviewed a lot of Jews Miko pillet is
one of them I always mention these names
because I consider him a friend he's
Israeli
Jew the Israeli media is playing this
shameful role of collaborating with the
occupation the government the Army the
secret Services don't want you to tell
and the consumers the readers and the
viewers don't want to hear and don't
want to know one day someone will ask
what what happened here how come that
this Society is living in this denial I
try to whistle in the darkness but I
don't think it has any influence on the
contrary you see that everything goes to
the opposite direction so what's the
point I remember I asked my father the
same question one day he said well I
don't want them to be able to say that
they didn't know yeah I cannot say they
didn't know famous Rabbi who lived in
jeruselam he was one of the anti-zionist
rabbis like like Rabbi Weiss that you
interviewed and he was interviewed by a
student of his and the student said to
him if um uh if you were in charge today
what will be the first thing that you
would do and this Rabbi said the first
thing I would do is I would ask the
Palestinians to come back and the
student says why what are you talking
about they're terrorists they want to
kill us and the rabbi his name is Rabbi
amam Rabbi amram Blau and the rabbi said
who told you that who told you that the
Arabs were going to kill us we had great
relations with the Muslims and the Arabs
back in the day you know his family
lived in Hebron and his half family
lived in Jerusalem that always had you
know Jewish minorities he said we had
great relations we Shar the same values
we Shar the similar culture you know we
all treat each other with respect it was
only only when the zionists came the
beginning of the 20th century that the
terrorism began that the violence began
and it was initiated not by the
Palestinians not by the Arabs and the
Muslims but by the zionists he wrote The
General son you have Rabbi Weiss Rabbi
Shapiro and others who've come out and
they're against this Zionist movement
this movement now that this is what
everything's revolving around here many
Jews believe wrongly that Zionism is
either part of Judaism or is compatible
with Judaism or is even the main part of
Judaism all of those are actually
false Zionism was created to negate
Judaism Zionism was created to replace
Judaism the differences between Zionism
and Judaism are vast they vast fast and
profound the propaganda that the
zionists have churned out for the past
100 years have confused and conflated
Zionism and Judaism such that when the
average person walks down the street he
thinks that the state of Israel is the
Jewish State he thinks that Zionism is
Judaism and he doesn't know the
difference this group of Jews here are
students of the students of the late
satma Rabbi Rabel tidle bam who was the
greatest de minator of the clarity
regarding the difference between Judaism
and Zionism so yeah Rabbi wise I
actually uh interviewed Rabbi wise oh
you met him you met the rabbi we met we
go to Muslim countries because it's a
requirement as the chief Rabbi of
Palestine RAB tidle bound said we are
required to let the world know that
these zionists and their state does not
speak for the Jewish people and they are
not um um in any way have the right to
use Judaism to oppress to steal the land
from the Palestinian people uh these
people who are good to us and we Babys
at each other's children we live
together they have no right to steal
from them the Torah doesn't permit you
to steal Zionist wants to confuse to
make it that there a religious conflict
nothing to do with religion on the
contrary the Muslims and the Arab people
were for us our friends and our patrons
the ones who protect us and provide a
safe haven and they should not be full
full victim of this evil movement of
Zionism with God's help if you remove
this impediment to peace Zionism a new a
relatively new ideology so 100 m years
then the Jews and Muslims and Christians
were living for hundreds and hundreds of
years and it was never a problem ah I
interviewed him I had a show called the
Islamic Show on Channel 30 in the
Washington DC area 25 years ago when I
was the Muslim chap of the American
University there so I I interviewed him
he's a friend and those people are
fair what advice would you would you
give just for the average uh person I've
also had um a Christian lady on she
represents the uh organization called if
Americans knew you know not to mention
the the3 billion dollar a year eight
billion just spent you know uh to to to
send when you have people here on the
streets you have people here you know
overrun with poverty some look like
they've been um taken back to uh they
you know the stone I mean they they've
been really inflicted by War some places
here in the US and people here need that
money and she makes this point also
other things you know she was somebody
who was also an an ENT supporter on one
end and then she really you know opened
her eyes and she got past the
programming that was happening so what
do you say to people you know if they
want to because they they're just being
programmed usually what they see on TV
the media and whatnot and they have an
agenda so what would you tell for people
to get a better understanding of what's
going on because I think anybody who who
looks into and sees you know open air
prism deprived the basic human
Necessities ba you know people who are
living in conditions worse than animals
you know people uh with any kind of God
Consciousness Awakening a heart you know
they would stand up you know a modern
day aparti what would you say how would
they get what's the best way to get
informed well the best way to get
informed is listen when you want to know
how a certain uh dish taste you have to
ask someone who tasted that dish you
can't go and ask people who
never saw that dish or tasted that dish
you have to go to Muslims go to any
mosque near you and and enter the mosque
and ask Muslims and you will see how
they welcome you how they tell you the
truth I don't shy from telling people
that yes there is combative Jihad I
didn't say that Jihad is only Jihad in
NS against one's ego no no why by the
way Islam is beautiful already it
doesn't need any plastic surgeries or
makeup I'm not going to beautify Islam
it is beautiful already and one of the
most beautiful things about Islam is
that it is based on evidence Islam I I
never well Islam is a religion of
Justice and Justice should be
established through peaceful means but
if Muslims fail to establish justice
through peaceful means Unfortunately
they have to resort to war guys this is
common sense I'm not saying something
strange
here so I wish that every American go to
the nearest mosque and ask people about
Islam ask us about Islam don't ask
people about
us yeah uh there's one verse I always
think about chapter 60 verse 8 it's so
beautiful just trumps all of this what a
lot of Islam put out where God Almighty
Allah is saying in the Quran that God
does not forbid you from dealing kindly
and justly with those who have not
fought you because your religion or
driven you out of your home this is such
a powerful beautiful
beautiful
yeah uh tell me now so you got to see
this PD pbd podcast with Patrick B David
and you wanted to um give some insights
personal insights uh that you because
you've been dealing with this a lot now
can you go ahead and share some of your
experiences yeah yeah well actually well
uh uh which which you mean the one that
had a
debate yes the one that had the debate
and his bigger vision of of Muslims and
Christians and others working together
because you have the sexualization of
the children and you've had many cases
now that this is being pushed pushed
down the throats of U of Muslims and
it's a deliberate attack and you've
actually Gone Gone even deeper and
you've gone to some of these conventions
and you've actually had uh some success
also in this area helping people who
yeah just go ahead and share it's coming
from you okay okay let me tell you what
well I I've been involved in this issue
of the alphabet movement and seeing what
they are doing and how they infiltrated
some of our uh uh children actually by
making them sympathize with them by
throwing on them false information and
misconceptions that we can actually
mention now but the issue is the only
two factions that are standing strongly
against this um uh destructive ideology
are the Christian right-wing and the
Muslims Christians right-wing have a big
problem with
Muslims I went several times to their
conferences I spoke to them and I told
them listen guys I'm not telling you
that we love you I'm not asking you to
love us but for the sake of our children
you need us and we need you so we need
to make a bridge let's make peace now
truth now and let's forget about that
you know I you know in one of these
conferences I'm there and someone one of
the the head of a big organization she's
texting me that Jesus is the son of God
and you have to accept that before we
work what's that you understand me I'm
not going to accept that and and I can't
debate with her on that I studied
Christianity like I studied Islam also
but I'm not there for that guys let's
put these things aside now and see how
can we do things together you see when
Muslims mobilized H uh uh uh uh in
Canada protest in Canada about a million
people went out in many cities it was it
was a success so how what if we join
hands together and do something together
because we are now on the defensive when
someone is on the defensive he's never
going to win a war you have to also
start uh things like for example go
making surveys about the countries that
banned the therapy of samex
Attraction we have to see what happened
since they banned it how many people
became suicidal because of the ban of
samesex attract because they told us
that they banned it they banned it
because uh it's a failure
and it makes people suicidal actually I
have a case of a boy who is becoming
suicidal because he cannot find a
therapist so that's the problem um we we
there's a lot of things that we can do
together there's a Str this is important
this is this is a great story uh can you
share that this so you had this um this
person who came to you and he wants to
start a family he want he has these uh
urges he has these desires and then what
happened he wants to suppress these
desires because God Almighty has given a
certain Avenue of how you can express
these desires that's through marriage
that's through man and woman coming
together but he was going in the
opposite direction so now he wanted if
I'm correct he wanted his mother to help
him to go and get him this kind of
therapy yeah therapist yeah but then
what happened from there I'll tell you
well actually this boy reached puberty
last year and he told his mom I have
good news and bad news the good news is
I had a wet dream the bad news is I have
a crush on my male friends but don't
worry Mom I went to the internet she he
was always raised by her a single mom
and I went to the internet and I found
that there's a therapy and the therapy
is uh about 50% success rate and uh it's
it's GNA be okay she said no listen they
are about to ban the therapy so I don't
have a problem that you go and live the
gay life he told her no don't say that
it's my dream to marry a woman like you
and have a child and a girl and name her
after you mom she said listen I don't
need any hassle I don't need problems
they are criminalizing the therapy
please I don't care go live the gay life
he said listen if you don't find me a
therapist I will take my
life so it looks like Banning the
therapy is also making people suicidal
because they told us it's it's the
therapy failed actually therapy doesn't
fail in every case no they bring you
cases with with whom the therapy has
failed well which therapy works 100% the
the question is does it work with some
people not it doesn't work with some
people every therap well cancer therapy
works with 20% who dares to to to to to
ban cancer therapy so actually I want to
tell you this because you know what I'm
GNA tell you even a a more interesting
story that happened to one of my friends
one of my friends who raised his
children in an Islamic school and when
they went to universities he felt that
they are changing they are they are
becoming more westernized speaking
things like uh sympathizing with the
alphabet movement and stuff like that so
he was really worried and his wife told
him listen they don't necessarily mean
what they say sometimes children just
test our limits so he wanted to see if
they really mean it or not so he called
his children his daughter was actually
married he told her I want you to come
on Tuesday at 6 leave your husband at
home don't bring him with you okay he
called the other two kids they were both
in University he told them come on
Tuesday at 6 the three of you I want you
there's an important information to tell
you he is separated from their uh from
their mother action so they expected
that he is going to tell tell them that
he's going to get married or something
like that they expected that so they
went his daughter is making tea Dad h
what did you want to say because I want
to go home he said no come here and sit
they sat he said listen I want to tell
you this I've been having same seex
attraction since a long time and I
haven't came out until today now I am
coming out to you your father is gay and
he is going to get married
and the children fell one of them fell
and the other one started to cry and his
daughter told him this is not a joke he
said why are you reacting like that I
never expected this homophobic reaction
from you you always sounded
open-minded and they broke up and they
told him no so he told him listen I was
I I'm it's not true I was just testing
to see if you really changed your
principles and your values or
not but that was mindblowing what he did
when he told me this I found it
mind-blowing actually anyway the issue
is I studied the issue and I found that
there are six main misconceptions that
they use to infiltrate our youth our
children mainly number one that Muslims
misunderstood the story
of and that homosexuality is not Haram
the problem of is that they were Bandits
cutting offroads attacking Travelers
traveling in Caravans and raping them
the second problem is or the second
misconception is that the Quran has a
mistake archaeologists proved that there
was homosexuality among the Pharaohs and
Prophet L said inah I
think lot when he said to his people do
you commit such obscenity with which no
one in all communities has proceeded you
how come he says so when the Pharaohs
had it the third misconception they say
it's not about sex it's about love what
if I wake up one day falling in love
with one of my male colleagues and this
is in my opinion the most dangerous one
because it depends on emotional
influence who can control his heart huh
the fourth misconception is that it is
not against F it's not against against
innate nature because it exists among
animals and so this means that it's
natural five therapy of same seex
attraction is a failure and it doesn't
work and it makes people suicidal and it
is immoral because torture is involved
in it that's what they say which is
completely false and I can prove it
Sixth and the last misconception
is this community deserves a special
treatment because they are oppressed and
persecuted in many countries and this is
also a false
statement so this number one we need to
answer all these six misconceptions for
our children so that they don't be don't
get fooled by anyone else uh uh and also
we need to understand what can we tell
our children in order to protect them
from these ideologies and there is um a
discourse or a rhetoric for children
under 11 years and for children over 11
years that can increase their level of
critical
thinking and also what can a parent do
if his child came back and told him that
he is transgender or she is
transgender what can you
do and uh or or maybe identifies himself
as a dog or a cat so we need to know
that also our children are asked by
islamophobes do Muslims hate
LGBT how can you answer this a proper
answer so this is very how to answer
Muslims themselves who ask are we at the
end of time because of of the spread of
these
ideologies because many Muslims today
are very desperate and they say we must
be at the end of time well People Said
So at the time of the
Crusades when they established for 90
years a a kingdom called the kingdom of
Jerusalem Crusades in in the middle of
the Muslim world people said this must
be the end of time and it wasn't the end
of time just a good respectable
generation appeared and pushed them out
and also after 150 years from that day
uh uh the Mongols invaded the Muslim
world and they slayed over one million
Muslims in Iraq they killed and they
slaughtered
Theif
Theif khif and Muslims at that said at
that time many of them said this must be
the end of time must be tomorrow and it
wasn't the end of time just a good rep
and respectable generation appeared and
pushed it out the issue is today we are
being
infiltrated uh by such ideologies the
spread of atheism the spread of these uh
uh sexual uh um uh misconduct and stuff
the issue is we may we may be at the end
of time and maybe not at every era there
is such things that happen fitna that
happens we can be the chosen ones that
Allah chose to face such ideologies and
Muslims have to understand that Islam
cannot just protect it itself against
these ideologies no Islam can defeat
them Islam is strong enough to defeat
them we just need to do one thing stop
whining and start working because we're
all the time
whining and complaining and no one is
doing it no we need to start working
planning and working that's that's what
I
believe last thing before we conclude so
now what I'm getting here is that uh
these these um this experience now with
the Christians was it at the end of the
day uh do you think this this is
something that together is going to have
a much stronger impact and when they see
that you know we're not the enemy I mean
you know you have others who others that
they sit and they they defend and
whatnot and the some of the others we
don't mention their names they can look
into it who actually curse Jesus who
actually curs his mother and whatnot I
mean I I just can't wrap my mind around
this I mean we're people who at the end
of the day we call Upon Jesus what he
called himself a messenger of God in the
Bible is called he was a servant a
messenger of God and we confirm that you
know we we a Muslim can end up in the
Hellfire saying one disrespectful thing
about Jesus peace be upon Him many
Christians have woken up to this fact
they don't I don't think they really
know this that's I think it's so
important that they know that how can
you be the enemy when you love and
Revere Jesus how how you don't you don't
say any disrespectful thing about him
how we need someone to build the bridge
between Us and Them believe me I always
had um uh hopes in Jordan Peterson but H
that he failed when Palestine is free
people like him are going to be ashamed
that they did this now I really have
hopes in uh Patrick uh uh Patrick Pat
yes I think he can build the bridges
between us let's not say that we need to
love each other now because looks like
the Gap is very big at least let's
cooperate in what is common we have
common values Family Values let's
cooperate together to save our children
and postpone for now the childish things
these these differences will never end
there will always be people who believe
in Jesus as lord and there will always
be people who don't believe in Jesus
except as a messenger and a prophet and
love him as well so let's leave these
things aside now and we really have to
work quickly I want to tell you
something we have a big problem that is
going going to um uh explode in our
faces very soon which is the
rainbow people religious people from the
Christian side and from the Muslim side
tell their five and six year old kids
that no they cannot buy them a bag with
a rainbow on it or or a t-shirt with a
rainbow on it because it's Haram it God
hates this but this means that you are
creating a complex in the child by
telling him that God hates Beauty
because it's the most beautiful
combination of colors so we need to work
together to redeem the rainbow the
rainbow has to be diluted it should not
mean anything not the their movement nor
anything but how to do so we need to
cooperate and we cannot do that as long
as they are distancing themselves from
us like that let's see if Patrick you
think Patrick I wish he can do Patrick B
David how he can replace uh you think
the uh Jordan Peterson it seems like
many see that he pretty much uh he sold
himself uh because he had one way of
thinking and then he jumped over to this
certain uh I think it was daily Wire
yeah he got a big paycheck and now his
whole his whole Direction Changed
fortunately fortunately unfortunately
yeah all right thank you very much he
God Almighty the Creator Allah bless you
and if people want to uh see some of
your documentaries uh there are many not
yet Muslims out there not watching and
they want to learn more about Islam
where can they see these documentaries
on you have our Channel actually this is
not a gas station that I work for this
is my organization Bridges foundation so
if you go to YouTube type Bridges
Foundation Channel it will appear to you
an ugly person will appear to you whom
is Myself And subscribe and there's a
lot of playlists one of them is called
the fog is lifting playlist it has the
three document we made uh part one is
called Islam in brief and part two is
called Jihad on terrorism 10 people
appear speaking on this uh in this
documentary five of them are non-muslims
two of them are Jews and all of them are
defending combative Jihad
scholarly and there is Islam in women
which is so you got you got you got you
got you got Jews in there also on this
documentary who are defending Jihad yes
of course yeah of course of course I
have a lot of Jewish Friends by the way
M so this dispels much of those myths
already we've I don't think someone can
watch this and still have uh hopefully
that uh by the way one of them one of
them is a very interesting person called
Dr Philip Sans he is the international
law professor in UCL in London and he
you know what he volunteered to defend
Guantanamo uh
prisoners wow Jewish attorney Jew I I'll
tell you more than that well in his
house we're filming with him and he said
if people are saying that uh this is
Terrorism they have to go and and see
the Jewish organizations who are blowing
buses and hotels in Palestine which is
now called Israel so I said cut cut
listen beautiful but can you please
repeat that but instead of saying Jewish
organizations say Zionist organizations
he said get out all of you you you
cowards they are attacking Islam I
didn't say anything wrong by the way go
tell them that I'm a Jew I said what he
said yes what's his name what's his
what's his Philip
S he's
amazing is he is he is he a self-hating
Jew definitely you know what they call
self-hating Jews I'm I'm sorry for the
word but it's called the list s h t
self-hating and Israel
threatening and I think we need the same
self-hating and Islam threatening and we
should have our list of people because
you know what these days a lot of those
appear and they surfaced on Twitter
attacking the oppressed and saying we
stand with Israel and they're supposed
to be Muslim we need this
list May um may the good people come
together who are really striving towards
Justice and peace
yeah and hopefully people can benefit
from this program we just did we'll see
you in the future inshallah God willing
thank you very much thank you very much
take caream peace be with you I'm sure
all of you know Eddie from the dean show
and I'm sure that you've all heard about
the dean center now you don't want to
miss on this opportunity the brother has
been around for a long time when I
became Muslim that was a show that I
used to watch it was one of the shows
that I actually was interviewed on and
since then I've kept in touch with Eddie
and we've cooperated and participate in
many things together alhamdulillah by
the blessings of Allah now you guys have
to do your part this is for the umah
there's so many people in this world who
need The Message of Islam but the
question is now what you going to do
what are you going to do with your money
with what you have what are you going to
do to help the umah to help someone
who's been around for 20 years doing
dawa you've enjoyed the shows you've
enjoyed the interviews you've enjoyed
now it's your turn support the Deans
[Music]
Center cannot leave without giving you a
gift if you're not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go ahead and visit theen
show.com we'll take care of the postage
and everything and get it delivered to
you and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum